bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir la
semaine où tout peut basculer sur le
corps n'a dit russe la fin des fêtes du
nouvel an risque d'aggraver la contagion
le seuil des 1000 morts a été franchi en
chine mais le risque est aussi politique
la défiance grandit contre la parole
officielle du régime coronavirus et si
le pouvoir de pékin était vraiment
menacée on en parle ce soir avec nos
invités
un numéro unique pour la scolarisation
pour tous des places supplémentaires
dans les établissements spécialisés
emmanuel macron a dévoilé son plan
handicap à l'elysée ce matin et il
rouvre le débat sur l'assistance
sexuelle des personnes handicapées le
droit à une vie intime les associations
le réclame la france l'interdît pourquoi
fois qu'ils changer la loi
nous en débattrons sur ce plateau enfin
eux veulent tout simplement des
explications pas des câlins nous serons
en direct de l'elysée où le président va
tenter ce soir de renouer le dialogue
avec une majorité de plus en plus
fracturées tous ces sujets on va d
aborder avec notre grand témoin il est
médecin ancien ministre de la santé en
serre secrétaire général adjoint des
nations unies philippe douste-blazy est
avec nous ce soir voilà vous savez tout
âge taille sévère n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir philippe
douste-blazy bonsoir et merci donc
d'être notre grand témoin plusieurs fois
ministre vous pilotez aujourd'hui unit
life c'est un programme de lutte contre
la malnutrition chronique notamment en
afrique et en asie vous aviez lancé il
ya quelques semaines un appel à l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
qu'elle élève son niveau d'alerté sur
locaux et rona des russes aujourd'hui l'
oms parle de menace très grave pour le
monde je la cite les critiques à l'égard
de pékin se multiplier le régime chinois
semblent là je dis bien semble ébranler
on en parle avec vous ce soir à liszt
heckmann bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes analyste responsable de l'asie à
l'institut d'études sur la sécurité de
l'union européenne spécialiste de la
chine vous publié cette semaine
rouge vif l'idéal communiste chinois
c'est aux éditions de l'observatoire ont
antoine bondage merci d'être là et
bonsoir vous enseigne à sciences po
paris spécialiste de la chine à la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique
et christophe najman bienvenue à vous
vous êtes député udi des vosges vice
président du groupe d'amitié france
chine vous avez vécu dans ce pays je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
celui qui ouvre le bal vous le savez
c'est stéphane stéphane blakowski pour
son billet si j'ai bien compris c'est
parti
[Musique]
bonsoir madame bon sens me rien de bon
soir messieurs bonsoir s'était fait
installer vous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris myriam la
dictature c'est pas le remède le plus
approprié pour empêcher la propagation
d'une épidémie pourtant au départ on
pourrait croire voit un régime
autoritaire comme machine
ils ont vraiment toutes les manettes ils
peuvent décider de manière efficace sans
tarder pas en tergiversant comme nous en
france 2 qu'on prend une décision
l'opposition est contre ça discute sans
arrêt sauf que là avec le coronavirus
c'est bien ça semble être le contraire
j'avais alors que trop de surprise
contre intuitif c'est exactement le
contraire se dire que en cas d'épidémie
le truc de plus important c'est de
réagir rapidement
parce qu'après ça devient impossible à
contrôler donc faut que l'information
circule et dans une argile autoritaire
c'est pas le cas donc le problème bas
régimes autoritaires c'est que une
épidémie avouer que c'est une très très
mauvaise nouvelle
or dans un régime autoritaire on sent
sur les mauvaise nouvelle évidemment
puisque tout doit bien se passer
vu que le régime responsable de tout et
que les dirigeants sont réalisés donc
forcément on on n'est jamais au courant
quand ça allait mal et c'est ce qui
s'est passé en chine la savoie là mais
puisqu'il y avait huit médecins donc à
l'ouvragé
plein de gens qui parlent chinois ils
pourront corriger huit médecins à wigan
l'avait dit bas sur les réseaux sociaux
attention il ya une épidémie faut réagir
ils ont été arrêtés par la police on les
a accusés propagation de fausses rumeurs
ils ont depuis été réhabilités mais l'un
d'entre eux est mort de la maladie il
est donc aujourd'hui acquis un statut de
martyr qui cristallise un peu là la
colère a d'ailleurs un reportage sur lui
at on va voir portable alors lé
dirigeant hors chine vous savez comme
moi sans fin est censé le savoir
moi c'est ce qu'on m'a dit à l'école
quand un dirigeant chinois fait une
erreur l'autocritique
donc il a été le maire de wang faire une
autocritique à la télévision et puis en
guise bat de d'explication il a trouvé
ben on écoute son excuse quand une
épidémie se déclenche nous avons une loi
pour lutter contre sa propagation
nous devons respecter cette loi avant de
livrer des informations en tant que
gouvernement local nous devons demander
l'autorisation avant de divulguer ces
informations
on a l'impression là que le maire de
roanne pointe le pouvoir central
m'étonnerait revoit sa tâche cachaça
mais bon ok ok on s'abrite il minimise
rentabilité en s'abritant derrière le
fait qu'il a totalement respecté la loi
mais bon ça résume bien la situation
puisque le pouvoir l'autorité locale la
tient du pouvoir central
donc c'est je vais en parler imposé en
france et des hommes politiques sont
élus ils donc ils peuvent mentir aux
électeurs pour garder leur poste ou
alors atténué la réalité alors que là
bas bien sûr si on doit mentir c'est aux
responsables centrale pour ne pas être
démissionnés comment on réagit justement
les autorités alors il ya quand même une
reprise en main du pouvoir justement
puisqu'on vient aussi dans un truc de
communication comme chez nous la
démocratie se diffuse un tout petit peu
en chine et donc il est apparu si jean
ping devant les caméras pékin avec la
masse qu'il a fait comme tout le monde
il a pris sa température ce qui fait que
finalement cela fait peu de descendre de
son estrade
bon en même temps voilà quand les
chinois allume la télé qu est ce qu ils
voient des reportages où l'armée est là
c'est la grande bataille du peuple et
bien sûr l'épidémie on va lui régler son
compte
les équipements médicaux les également
du personnel ceux des docteurs et des
infirmières tout cela a bien été
préparée en gros nous sommes confiants
ce sont gagné ce combat
en revanche sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas du tout même son cloche
exactement le régime et autoritaire mais
par rapport à 2002 au strass c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de contrôler
même si la chine on sait le fait les
réseaux sociaux on en arrive à diffuser
des vidéos des messages que les gens
voient et qui bien sûr n'ont pas du tout
le même traitement de la réalité que les
reportages de la télévision officielle
une vidéo qui a été tournée le 1er
février awanou quelqu'un arrive à
l'hôpital on avait trois l'instant
laisse-moi compter les corps 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 8 au total vient de mourir quand
est-ce que ça s'est passé hier
oh mon dieu
il ya plein de morts c'est le banc
département je viens d'entrer il ya
quelqu'un qui bouge décor la question
maintenant c'est ce que est ce que tu
dit ping est fragilisé on a tous les
experts sur le plateau pour nous
apprendre à cette question mais moi je
ne suis pas trop inquiet en tout cas
pour lui même s'il est fragilisé et un
peu de chance vous le dirai pas ce qui
c'est le contraire qu'il ya un mouvement
type gilet jaune en chine
il semblerait moi que si on disait xi
jingping des missions sont brandies à sa
tête sur une pique pense qu'ils auraient
une répression un peu plus férocement
france
bon allez on va débattre à présent je
vous propose qu'on parte des chiffres
après se disait de stéphane est ce qu'on
peut leur faire confiance à l'iss
heckmann 1000 18 morts 43 mille
personnes contaminées par le virus est
ce que les chiffres de pékin sont faux -
c'est-à-dire difficile aujourd'hui de
vérifier ces chiffres je ne suis pas sur
le terrain à l'heure où je vous parle il
ya un débat assez anciens sur les
chiffres en chine vos statistiques
notamment économique là sur les
statistiques je pense que maintenant il
y a eu tellement de débats au début de
la crise sur le nombre justement sur ces
chiffres sur le nombre de morts qui
n'auraient pas été déclarés car il ya eu
plusieurs et plusieurs étapes de
comptage avec aussi des temps d'absence
de comptage est aussi en tout cas des
temps de non diffusion du comptage et
des temps de mise à jour de ses dix
finales des silences par ailleurs
alimenté les doutes sur la fiabilité
on est là dans une stratégie en tout cas
d'entente dans des enjeux de
communication alors que le monde regarde
la chine la chine essaye de communiquer
au maximum sur le chiffre en tout cas le
fait davantage qu'au début de la crise
moi même je n'ai pas les instruments
pour vérifier ces chiffres ici sur place
philippe douste-blazy vous aviez alerté
l oms en disant il faut absolument
monter en gamme le niveau d alerte
le docteur tedros le directeur général
de l'om s10 aujourd'hui nous nous voyons
peut-être que le sommet de l'iceberg
il parle de quoi à la ddt ce qui se
passe en chine ou du risque sur
l'ensemble de la planète mais c'est à
dire qu'il ya ce que l'on sait ce que
l'on connaît c'est à dire plus de 1000
morts 42 mille ou 45000 lait contaminé
on sait que lorsque quelqu'un a le virus
il va à peu près transmettre entre deux
et trois personnes deux et demi
personne et on sait que le taux de
mortalité est entre 1 et 2,4 pour cent
ça on le sait ce que l'on ne sait pas
maintenant c'est ce qui va se passer
il faudrait que l'om est maintenant et
un petit mail oms envoie une mission
internationale d'experts sur vous la
dirigez par un scientifique canadien qui
s'est occupée des baux là ils peuvent
travailler
certes c'est possible de leur donner des
informations c'est à dire que je crois
qu'ils sont là bas mais non nous sommes
surtout avec un peu de retard
tokyo ms aurait dû être là depuis le
premier jour je me semble-t-il
elle a failli même nom l'om et c'est là
qu'est ce qu'ils vont regarder ce qu'il
faut regarder c'est une chose est ce que
ce que vous avez dit était la fois vrai
et faux c'est dire que ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il y à eut retiré à l'allumage
entre le 15 décembre et le première
semaine de janvier à paris le 20 janvier
fiscal voilà mais par contre le 8
décembre et deux pays au monde
quel est le pays au monde qui aurait dit
qu'il faut confiné 60 millions de
personnes en tout cas en europe
oubliez serait déjà partout se dirige sa
famille et avoir construit un hôpital en
10 jours mais malgré tout on parlait des
chiffres départ au début de l'épidémie
il ya un médecin à hong kong avec
gabriel langue il s'appelle justement un
calcul en disant on nous dit 4000 cas
moi je dirais bien vingt fois plus donc
gabriel donc je vais en parler parce que
c'est actuellement il ya deux grandes
écoles en épidémiologie je suis petit
biologiste d'un côté il y à columbia qui
dit normalement devrait avoir un pic des
deux prochaines semaines
et puis petit risque quand même c'est le
sursaut puisque les gens finissent leurs
vacances alors on y lit voeux du nouvel
an le 9 février et prenez les quatre
villes les quand les grandes villes
chinoises de plus de 20 millions
d'habitants
pékin 24 millions il y à 8000 y avait
huit millions de gens en dehors de pékin
au moment donc le retour au travail va
forcément arriver début le risque de
contagion est de fait et ensuite gabriel
ringlet la question est extrêmement
importante c'est de dire parler les
chiffres en 6ème et est-ce qu'on peut
faire confiance à pékin
non mais d'abord pékin deux côtés a eu
du retard à l'allumage répète
deuxièmement ils ont confiné 60 millions
personne ça il faut quand même là il
faut quand même leur dire merci pour ça
quand même parce que c'est pas évident
de le faire la question qui est posée
qui est importante
est ce que des mesures drastiques qu'ils
ont prises sont les bonnes mesures
et ça personne ne sait aujourd'hui quels
sont les résultats
si la réponse est oui moi je le crois
elles sont efficaces
alors ça veut dire que dans les villes à
côté les pays à côté comme la thaïlande
ils ont commencé à confiner très bien
mais en indonésie 300 millions de
personnes 0 donc la question que l'om
est de se poser très vite
est ce que oui ou non ces mesures en
chine sont efficaces et si oui il faut
le faire ne les payer à côté reste après
la question en effet de la montée
exponentielle dit gabrielle lahoud qui
est tout à fait possible dans les jours
qui viennent sur les villes chasse que
même si la mortalité faut le dire est
reste faible la propagation 3% vous
trouvez que c'est vous sait très bien
que la progression est assez important
et surtout ce qui n'est pas normal mais
je pense que mon voisin va le dire ce
qui n'est pas normal c'est que lorsque
vous comparez le taux de mortalité
haouran et vous comparer le taux de
mortalité à ce gang ou ailleurs ou en
cloud vous voyez que c'est pas pareil
donc ça veut dire que le numérateur ou
le dénominateur et quelque part
falsifiés quelque part contentieux le
monde dur partout partout par exemple et
surtout ils pensaient alors là
premièrement et deuxièmement en chine
il n'a pas la même virulence que ça
c'est pas normal antoine monde qu'est ce
qui va changer avec la fin des fêtes du
nouvel an concrètement on va revenir au
travail d'ondés dans des provinces comme
le québec il ya aura de l'épicentre
tout le monde reste confiné il faut être
extrêmement clair vous avez de
nombreuses villes qui restent confinés
où la mise en quarantaine se poursuit et
même renforcé par exemple ce soir à
bourg ain vous ne pouvez plus sortir
quand vous le voulez vous devez avoir un
laissez-passer vous ne pouvez sortir
qu'une fois tous les trois jours donc
les mesures de restrictions de
déplacements sont renforcés à voir dans
la province du hubei les questions qui
se posent sont dans les provinces qui
sont plus
éloigné du foyer de l'épidémie où la
reprise du travail allait partiel elle
n'est pas totale quelques usines
rouvrent pas tout par exemple les usines
de foxconn les usines d'un sous traitant
d'apple qui produisent notamment les
iphone dans la province du guandong donc
au nord de hong kong restent fermés et
toutes les provinces à risque restent
fermés le principal problème pour les
autorités à pékin c'est que la stratégie
initiale a été de circonscrire la crise
de façon spatiales et de façon
temporaire c'est à dire qu'en faire une
crise our âme et d'en faire une crise de
courte durée or le principal problème
auquel les autorités font face
aujourd'hui c'est que la crise elle est
évidemment nationale non pas seulement
puisqu'il ya des cas sur l'ensemble du
territoire ça ça fait déjà deux à trois
semaines
mais que des mesures de restrictions de
déplacements ont été prises dans
l'ensemble des provinces en chine et
deuxièmement c'est une crise qui est là
pour durer au moins sur le moyen voire
long terme
et ça c'est évident dans les différentes
annonces qu'on a du gouvernement et
surtout du parti en jeu christophe
naegelen vous vous êtes membre donc vice
président de ce groupe d'amitié france
chine vous dit quoi à nos ressortissants
revenez et à ceux qui voudraient partir
je sais que votre soeur est revenu est
revenu hier par tes parents ne repartait
pas bien entendu en fait on a vraiment
de crise une qui est de la province du
hubei et après sur le reste de sur le
reste de la chine
est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure et
tout à fait exact le roubaix est
complètement fermé toutes les villes qui
sont dans cette province
mais même shanghai si on prend shanghai
aujourd'hui toutes les entreprises
depuis dix jours sont fermés mis à part
les principales entreprises de
télécommunications et autres couvrir
vont elles vont mourir contre le tram
avec énormément de télétravail pour les
entreprises qui le peuvent
j'avais des expatriés téléphone pas plus
tard qu'aujourd'hui qui vont qui font du
télétravail et on leur demande de
continuer à en faire
il ya un problème en face
inflationnistes aussi parce que c'est à
dire que toute la nourriture prend
commence à prendre des proportions assez
importante parce qu'il ya un problème de
ravitaillement aux éperons que c'est une
réalité non seulement pour les chinois
mais aussi pour les expatriés qui qui
vivent qui vivent sur place
ebrima promet de punir ceux qui
profiteront à la situation
oui mais un moment donné vous savez la
problématique avec la chine ce convoi
est ce qu'on voit pas ce qu'on voit le
message qu'ils ont voulu faire passer
c'est quoi c'est on est extrêmement
rapide extrêmement réactif on a
construit un hôpital en dix jours mais
ça ça a été un message on a vu des
vidéos que là dessus
deuxième point on compte la province de
du roubaix personne ne peut sortir
donc grosso modo roncq ont toutes les
personnes qui sont infectées dans cette
province là et ne vous inquiétez pas
pour toutes les autres villes on va on
va gérer d'ailleurs si on regarde on
parle de 42 mille personnes infectées en
chine est de 43 1800 personnes affectées
sur le reste du globe donc 1800
personnes
le reste du monde 42 mis en quarantaine
effectivement je vois qu'on parle quand
même de la dimension politique de cette
crise
on a parlé de la censure on va tout de
suite voir au fond celui qui a incarné
un peu
visage martyrs de cette épidémie il
s'appelle donc lee won lee yang et les
médecins il avait pris la liberté de
discuter sur internet avec des confrères
dans le monde pour remettre en cause la
version officielle du régime c'est lui
qui a joué les premiers lanceurs d'alert
pour de plus en plus de chinois
c'est la censure qui l'a tué ahmed tazir
l' annonce a fait l'effet d'une bombe
vendredi dernier le couronne à virus
fait une nouvelle victime
liu xiang un jeune ophtalmologue de 34
ans c'est l'un des premiers à avoir
alerté sur l'apparition de l'épidémie
à l'époque il avait été accusé de
diffuser de fausses rumeurs convocation
au poste de police et sommation de se
taire le médecin est devenu aujourd'hui
un symbole celui de la lutte contre
l'opacité du système chinois à hong kong
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont
participé à une veillée funèbre pour lui
rendre hommage le sifflet pour ne pas
oublier le lanceur d alerte
un décès commenté aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux chinois une avalanche de
messages de tristesse et de colère
on peut lire n'oublions jamais dr lee ce
médecin qui a parlé d'une maladie
appelée rumeurs les censeurs ont été
littéralement débordés par la colère des
internautes et le mouvement de
contestation grandit contre les
autorités et leur gestion
l'exemple de cet activiste est
révélateur cet avocat s'est reconverti
en journaliste il rend compte depuis
uran de la situation sur place et dans
les hôpitaux chaîne qui diffuse aussi
des vidéos qu'il a tourné comme celle de
cette patiente ampleur qui se plaint que
son cas ne soit pas prise au sérieux
je tousse depuis six joueurs et vous
venez me dire que les symptômes ne sont
pas graves ne répétait plus jamais cela
ou alors de cet homme sur un fauteuil
roulant est ce qu'elle va bien il est
décédé
il est mort oui
[Musique]
si je survis ici je raconterai tout ce
que j'ai entendu et vu gouvernement
chinois
je n'ai pas peur de vous mais depuis
jeudi dernier plus aucune trace de
l'activiste et voilà les réseaux sociaux
qui prennent de vitesse l'administration
chinoise
en réponse les autorités annoncent leur
mise sous surveillance spéciale pour
contrôler plus strictement les
informations diffusées en ligne un
tournevis supplémentaire dans la censure
qui montre l'inquiétude du régime
chinois
alice heckmann je voudrais qu'on
s'attarde sur ses critiques à l'égard du
pouvoir les réseaux sociaux est ce que
c'est véritablement inédit
ces scènes de sifflements pour critiquer
au fond le silence des autorités on a vu
des hashtags sur la liberté d'expression
des mots qui disent je ne comprends pas
notamment après après la mort du médecin
est-ce qu'on est là on est on sait ce
qui s'est passé à hong kong mais là on
est ailleurs donc est ce que ces
nouveaux est-ce que l'ampleur de la
critique est plus importante que par le
passé les critiques sont bonnes
nouvelles il ya une nombreuses critiques
en chine des mouvements sociaux en ligne
ou hors ligne sur par exemple
d'entreprises polluantes sur le système
enfin sur la situation environnementale
en chine généralement il a eu aussi des
mouvements sociaux venant des migrants
là il ya eu un cas vraiment
cristallisant et puis le fait de la
gravité du sujet qui touche un grand
nombre de personnes et puis il ya aussi
de l'émotion qui s'est cristallisée sur
ce docteur dit wang yang dong il ya eu
réunion de quiet man et critique c'est
la genèse principalement c'est ses
clientes cet oubli il ya plus d'un
milliard de commentaires suite à sa mort
donc je pense qu'à une diversité de
perception et d'émotion mais d'un point
de vue analytique d'un point de vue
aussi d'analystes politiques au sens
strict je pense qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer
l'efficacité de la censure c'est à dire
c'est une censure qui reste forte à
géométrie variable qui s'est renforcée
au cours du temps comme l'indiqué le le
reportage est aujourd'hui la chine a les
moyens technologiques et humains de
contrôler très rapidement même s'il a
été dépassé à un moment donc je pense
que pour la fleur en fleur il ya d'un
côté c'est un organe de propagande
c'est dans ces ados de deux manières
c'est à la fois ya la censure c'est à
dire la suppression de contenu mais
aussi la création de contenu favorables
et positifs avec maintenant une
développement de nouveaux éléments de
langage de promotion de deux ans
suppression de contenu est ce que les
sites sont fermés dax d'accès à des
sites d'information c'est que les
réseaux sociaux sont très populaires en
chine
quels sont les moyens de la censure
concrètement est ce qu a aussi des
arrestations un faux est clair
aujourd'hui il est impossible pour pékin
de bannir complètement les réseaux
sociaux pour une raison simple c'est
qu'ils n'ont jamais été aussi utile dans
la vie des gens puisque quand vous êtes
confiné chez vous c'est votre seul lien
social avec votre famille avec vos amis
donc ce serait extrêmement impopulaire
de les bannir complètement ce qui est
sûr c'est que comme toujours en chine le
flux d'informations et canaliser il est
contrôlé et il n'ya pas d'expressions
parfaitement libre le cas des lieux wang
yang est vraiment emblématique puisque
c'est un révélateur des problèmes de
gouvernance en chine c'est un révélateur
des effets néfastes de la censure puis
c'était un personnel de santé et les
personnels de santé sont évidemment mise
en avant depuis déjà trois semaines par
la propagande chinoise et à juste titre
présentés comme des soldats sur le front
de cette guerre contre l'épidémie et
donc c'est pour ça que la colère et
l'émotion était très importante mais là
où pékin a réagi de façon assez rapide
c'est non seulement à travers la censure
à travers la production de contenus
comme le disait à lizac man puis c'est
aussi en ayant pris des mesures qui
permettent de calmer momentanément ce
n'est devenu un héros même dans les
médias aujourd'hui cela m'aide c'est
pour ça que c'est la réhabilitation a
posteriori mais c'est pour ça aussi que
vous avez un envoi par pékin c'est à
dire de l'état central vers les
gouvernements locaux du comité
d'inspection pour essayer entre
guillemets de trouver des responsables
aux niveaux locaux et on a déjà appris
par exemple aujourd'hui la démission de
deux responsables du ministère de la
santé au niveau de la province au niveau
commence à faire le ménage
dernière question pour h vers ceux de ce
tour de table pour terminer il est
fragilisé ou pas ce régime ou vraiment
la cdu commentaires on est dans un
régime extrêmement puissant shipping a
renforcé d'ailleurs le portico il a
remis au centre du jeu enfin évidemment
kevin big ne va pas tomber sur ce
problème
non ce qui est intéressant sur le plan
politique c'est que tous les chefs
d'état et en particulier tous les
dictateurs plus ou moins fort pense même
en occident d'air que ce qui est
important c'est le régal hier alors
c'est l'armée c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est la justice
bah non il se trouve que le ministère de
la santé et la santé publique c'est
extrêmement important dans un pays
or ce système de santé public chinois il
est purement centralisée et lorsque
quelqu'un aujourd'hui à 37,3 sur le
thermomètre électronique electronic
qu'on le prend dans la rue en amène ce
monsieur cette dame aux urgences de
l'hôpital c'est tout ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire parce que c'est justement il
faut le confiner surtout pas l'amener à
l'hôpital
aujourd'hui le système de santé public
chinois est pris à son propre piège
justement parce qu'il est centralisé et
ça ça peut être extrêmement intéressant
pour tous les chefs d'état qui regarde
ça s'apercevoir que dans une politique
il faut certes avoir peut-être des armes
effroyables parce que ça nous intéresse
beaucoup
mais la santé publique c'est peut-être
ce cas de plus important est d'ailleurs
dans une grande ville
le maire de bourg ain le sait mieux que
personne
une grande ville doit avoir un système
de santé publique
aussi pour les citoyens a mis en place
le ministère de la santé
mais alors concédé le sans faute dès
lors que les dés lors qu'il y a les
symptômes
n'allez surtout pas l'hôpital mais
contacter le 15
donnez vos symptômes et vous serez le
ministère de la santé français
aujourd'hui fait un sans faute ce set
qui montrent surtout que l'agent santé
publique france sur cette agence d'état
est aujourd'hui après disque
opérationnellement très opérationnelle
est un gars retiendra ce bon point pour
notre pays sur cette crise
sanitaires très préoccupante merci
infiniment philippe douste-blazy vous
savez évidemment de quoi on parle
la préoccupation principale ici les
bonbons de quoi parlent les députés de
la réforme des retraites absolument
c'est l'heure du point retrait des dames
on va rester avec nos bons soirs hasard
bonsoir alors c'est poussif c'est
parfois laborieux ça a été même un petit
peu comique par moments ça reste
studieux à cette commission spéciale
elle va bientôt prendre sa retraite
aussi exactement même si il reste
quatorze mille amendements ce soir les
députés
eh bien ils vont acté que tout
simplement ils n'auront pas le temps
d'aller au bout des travaux c'est pas
une surprise tout le monde le sait une
conférence des présidents devra quand
même acté cette décision ce sera soit ce
soir soit demain matin petite précision
demain on étudie quand même le projet de
loi organique en commission alors côté
majorité on a essayé de faire ça dans
les règles constitutionnelles puisque
c'est assez inédit ici à l'assemblée
mais évidemment chaque camp se renvoie
la balle pour la majorité bien c'est
l'extraordinaire nombre d'amendements
qui a bloqué le travail de la commission
et puis pour les oppositions bien c'est
le gouvernement qui n'a tout simplement
pas prévu assez de temps pour examiner
un texte si important que ça voudrait
dire que cette commission et n'a servi à
rien commence à 0 elle a pas servi à
grand chose effectivement puisque en
séance publique et bien on reprend le
texte originel du gouvernement oui mais
tout ce travail effectué et bien ça
quand même servi à défricher un texte
qui compte beaucoup d'articles beaucoup
de mesure et de pointer quelques flous
par exemple l'indicateur sur lequel sera
revalorisée ce fameux point ces points
qu'on va acquérir tout au long de la
carrière depuis le début l'exécutif nous
dit ce sera sur les salaires donc vous
d'inquiéter ne vous inquiétez pas ça ne
pourra jamais baissé et puis en
commission dit ce sera sur le revenu
moyen d'activités pour la majorité c'est
un détail sémantique ou mais sauf que
cet indicateur là n'existent pas encore
c'est l insee de le créer ça les
oppositions vont pas manqué de le
rappeler c'est sûr ça a commencé
d'ailleurs à créer une grosse grosse
polémique notamment sur
et réseaux sociaux le point d'indicé
comment sera-t-il calculé le point de la
retraite donc le débat va continuer à
partir du 17 lundi dans l'hémicycle avec
au fond les mêmes questions le
calendrier la course contre la montre
les municipales quels sont les scénarios
et bien écoutez selon le gouvernement le
scénario idéal un peu c'était deux
semaines d'examen pour un vote solennel
le 3 mars ensuite on ferme l'assemblée
deux semaines pour la trêve des
élections municipales
oui mais ce calendrier il a déjà du
plomb dans l aile on pense qu'on va
ouvrir une troisième semaine
et pourquoi pas siégé pendant les
municipales finalement la fermeture elle
est d'usagé mais elle est pas
obligatoire ça les oppositions ne
veulent pas en entendre parler
et bien la majorité leur dit défendez un
peu moins d'amendements philippe
douste-blazy comment vous regardez ce
débat les français n'y arrive plus
ils ne comprennent plus ce qu il se
passe tellement c'est technique je
connais un peu cette maison a présenté
des projets de lois et de l'autre
j'étais président de groupe à
l'assemblée depuis je connais un peu
en fait il ya deux choses que vous avez
dit qu'ils sont tout à fait différentes
la première c'est un travail formidable
de l'opposition ou de la majorité sur le
point le fameux point de cannabis ça
c'est du vrai travail politique de fonds
de fonds franchement je trouve ça un peu
choquant quand même que l'on puisse par
des robots pratiquement faire des
amendements on sait très bien que c'est
du blocage construction à la fin
seulement aucune évidemment aucun
conseil à donner à personne mais moi je
pense qu'il faut rester jour et nuit
jusqu'à ce que le dernier amendement ps
passé pour montrer que l'opposition ne
peut pas gagner sur ce type de
comportement parce que il y a plus de
kilomètres carrés moi ça fait 13 ans 14
ans que j'habite dans tous les pays du
monde pour une itt est définitif
eh bien il ya beaucoup plus de
kilomètres carrés dans le monde où il
n'ya pas de démocratie que de kilomètres
carrés et des démocraties cette maison
c'est sacré cette maison c'est le maison
du peuple français il faut vous faire
attention à ça c'est extrêmement fragile
il faut pas s'amuser avec démocratie et
on oublie parfois que voilà et bien
démographie sont sont précieux merci on
va maintenant parler d'un autre sujet
il est fondamental parce qu'il traverse
notre société il s'agit du handicap
avant de détailler les mesures annoncées
par le président de la république ce
matin cette question pourquoi y at il si
peu de personnes handicapées en
politique philippe douste-blazy vous ne
répondrez mais d'abord hélène bonduelle
et nattier des guides et noir ont suivi
le seul des députés handicapés dans
l'hémicycle il s'appelle damien abad et
il s'est confié à la fois sur son
engagement et sur les raisons de ce
retard criant reportage le président des
républicains à l'assemblée nationale
assure ce n'est pas son handicap une
arthrose grippe aux bloquant ses
articulations qui l'a convaincu de
s'engager en politique
pour damien abad ça n'a été ni un moteur
ni un frein même si les premières
difficultés de sa vie de militant sont
vite apparues ce qui a été dur saisissez
le premier tractage sur les marchés
c'est la première rencontre avec les
gens c'est le premier pas que vous allez
franchir
bien sûr vous avez une barrière
supplémentaire après ça empêche pas vous
savez mes adversaires se gêne pas pour
critiquer c'est tant mieux parce que
c'est aussi ça la politique donc donc
voilà c'est la preuve d'intégration bien
sûr comme nicolas sarkozy a rien de pire
que l'indifférence pour lutter contre
l'indifférence
il présente en 2013 une proposition de
loi qui impose un volet handicap dans
chacune des lois défendu au parlement
ce sera son premier axe politique d'élus
nationale celui qui a aussi été le plus
jeune député européen 29 ans s'étonne
qu'en france il est si peu d'élus
handicapés au parlement européen être
député et handicapées c'est pas une
exception et j'étais avec moi j'avais un
député auront droit qui était soutenu et
j'avais d'autres personnes qui étaient
en fauteuil
et donc c'était rentrer dans le droit
commun en france effectivement je suis
seul député en situation de handicap
ce que je voudrais c'est qu'il y ait
bien dans plein d'autres exemples
merci merci bon et cela passe d'abord
par l'accessibilité
le député a bien un assistant
fonctionnel qui l'accompagnent dans les
tâches quotidiennes de son mandat il y à
bien aussi quelques rampes d'accès aux
fauteuils roulants dans les couloirs
mais le vieux palais du xviiie siècle
n'est pas vraiment adapté à l'est dans
l'hémicycle et vous verrez l'étroitesse
des lieux la difficulté pour pouvoir
s'asseoir sur son siège
moi même il a fallu faire des travaux
cassé du mobilier classé pour que je
puisse
étaler mes jambes parce que je peux pas
payer mes genoux et donc forcément c'est
toujours un peu paradoxal que le lieu où
on fait la loi ne soit pas accessible
il y a deux ans pour permettre au
président du parlement allemand
handicapées d'accéder à la tribune
les huissiers doivent même porté son
fauteuil roulant l'assemblée nationale
comme beaucoup trop de vieux bâtiment
souffre d'un problème d'accessibilité
je reçois beaucoup de personnes de ma
circonscription à l'assemblée nationale
quand des personnes en situation de
handicap viennent ici ça n'est pas
simple pour les non voyants les
malentendants il ya des marges de
progression immense affaire donc oui là
le chaudron de la république doit être
exemplaire dans ce domaine là il ya des
marges de progression
voilà et pour débattre de ce plan
handicap qui a été annoncée ce matin par
le président de la république à l'élysée
et du droit à la vie intime à la vie
sexuelle des personnes handicapées
plusieurs invités nous ont rejoints sur
ce plateau
patricia assouline bonsoir soir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes handicapé
depuis votre naissance et vous militez
pour l'assistance sexuelle des personnes
handicapées vous avez même recours
régulièrement à des aidants à des
accompagnants sexuelle vous prenez
d'ailleurs le risque ce soir de le dire
haut et fort alors que la loi l'interdît
donc merci à vous on va en parler plus
longuement tout à l'heure ça brice la
jeune bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
vous-même aidants sexuels vous êtes venu
de lyon pour cette émission merci à vous
vous êtes membre de la passe
l'association pour la promotion de
l'accompagnement sexuel enfin bon soir
olivier paolini président fondateur de
l'inclusion en marche c'est une
association vous êtes chargé au fond de
suivre ces questions liées au handicap
au sein du parti des manuels macron un
seul député
on va venir à vos sujets mais pour
rebondir sur un seul député qui
souffrent d'un handicap sur 577
les quelque chose qui va pas quand même
nuit à 2 millions de personnes
handicapées en france c'est le regard en
réalité de la société qu'il faut que
nous changions beaucoup d'autres pays
ont fait des progrès considérables
nous sommes restés prudents chirac il ya
15 ans avaient commencé à ouvrir une
porte
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire que ce soit l'accessibilité dans
tout après tout à l'heure on s'est rendu
compte même qu'à la tramblais c'était
compliqué non mais surtout dans les îles
c'est à dire que il ya juste un petit
endroit où il ya des rampes et elle
était posée à l'envers donc là on a
failli y parvenir
oui la démarche sur l'accessibilité les
filles qui ne permet pas parce que c'est
un vieux bâtiment vieilles constructions
aux députés qui auraient des difficultés
pour tout simplement s'asseoir ça semble
quand même incroyable le retard alors il
maniait le maquereau a bien saisi le
problème
vous le savez avec sa fameuse de temps à
venir mais là je parlais des députés des
politiques et des handicapés regardez en
allemagne il y à wolfgang schauble qui
est quand même le redouté qui a été
redoutable ministre des finances de
l'économie c'est lui qui a négocié la
crise grecque
il est dans un fauteuil et ça ne pose
aucun problème la représentativité des
personnes handicapées en politique fait
défaut en france
il faut absolument faire émerger une
nouvelle classe politique qui soit
beaucoup plus représentatives des
personnes handicapées vous le disiez une
personne sur 5 12 millions de personnes
en france sont en situation de handicap
le le personnel politique doit se
mobiliser nous avons bientôt des
élections municipales
moi j'invite un maximum de personnes
handicapées à venir s'engager en
politique pour pour koné loin du compte
alors on va parler de ce plan de façon
un peu général et puis vous nous direz
au fond comment vous vivez à la fois le
travail que vous faites cet engagement
et cette association pour pour
l'accompagnement sexuel regardons
d'abord dans l'ensemble ces annonces la
principale d'entre elles elle et elle
est symbolique c'est une promesse plus
aucun enfant sans scolarisation alors la
rentrée prochaine plus aucun enfant
handicapé en dehors de l'école c'est le
président qui l'a annoncé ce matin
alors non pas je vous donnais les
mesures est ce qu'on écoute le président
ou est-ce que je vous donne les mesures
allaient les mesures c'est parti donc on
a regardé quatre camps de mesures la
création d'un numéro unique le 360
le recrutement
11500 ash il s'agit d accompagnement des
élèves en situation de handicap des
droits aussi avis et ça c'est nouveau
pour les personnes victimes d'un
handicap irrémédiable et puis le délai
d'attribution de l'allocation pour les
personnes handicapées qui est devrait ne
pas excéder trois mois maximum
la promesse d' emmanuel macron sur les
enfants ont l'écoutent matin pour moi le
premier objectif c'est qu'aucun enfant
sans solution de scolarisation ne puisse
encore exister en mois de septembre
prochain
1 en stabilisant des vrais contrats des
emplois bien payés correctement
2 on va poursuivre le recrutement on
vise le recrutement de 11500
accompagnant supplémentaires d'ici 2022
faudra ajuster en fonction des besoins
alors ce plan était très très attendu la
loi chirac remonte à 2005
il vous semble à la hauteur j'imagine
tout à fait oui oui à l'ouverture par
claude chirac était présente ce matin à
la scène à la cnh montres bières le sens
qu'on veut donner par rapport à la loi
de 2005 et le projet porté par le
président de la république a sion la
scolarisation l'idée c'est qu'aucun
enfant ne reste sans solution et que
l'école soit pleinement inclusive alors
moi j'aime plutôt parler d'une
transition inclusive a effectivement il
ya beaucoup de difficultés encore sur le
terrain les familles le savent et on va
encore mettre encore beaucoup de temps
pour y arriver
l'idée c'est d'arriver en 2021 2022 à
une école qui soit pleinement inclusive
et donc pour ça là le recrutement de
11000 un message supplémentaire dans les
deux ans qui viennent va permettre de
monter en puissance sur cette école
exclusive le regard a changé sur le
handicap
la société change aussi est ce que le
législateur le politique suit et arrive
véritablement à être à la hauteur des
attentes
non mais ce qui est très triste c'est
que beaucoup de loi existe beaucoup de
discours ont été faits mais cédant dans
les faits que ça ne suit pas par exemple
je pense que la bureaucratie j'ai été
maire pendant une vingtaine d'années
donc
la bureaucratie lorsque vous avez un
enfant handicapé frère un père soeur et
que vous attendez des mois des mois et
des mois
le papier qui va vous permettre ensuite
d'avoir la place les démarches
administratives on vous demande toujours
de prouver à nouveau vous avez bel et
bien sûr c'est ça qui est important
d'assurer et 5000 personnes qui partent
en belgique c'est pas axa aussi en fait
le président s'engage à cesser en fait
cet exil un délégué de vous avez été
attentive aux différentes annonces qui
ont été faites aujourd'hui bas
concernant l'inclusion des enfants en
tapant ce qu'on l'arrêtait je trouve ça
est très bien parce que moi de mon temps
parce que je suis un peu plus âgée j'ai
toujours été dans des institutions fin
dans des écoles spécialisées
alors c'est vrai que c'est à dire qu'il
ya dans ces institutions là on est
encadré
mais c'est le médical qui prône sur la
scolarité et du coup c'est vrai que en
tout cas pour ma part on a tendance a
accumulé beaucoup de retard et beaucoup
de lacunes scolaires parce que tout est
axé sur la médicalisation les le kiné le
voilà le tout et rgo la voie en
permanence un nous renvoie votre
handicap et du trouvé que le regard a
changé
il avance doucement ils avancent
doucement pas encore comme comme il
faudrait mais où est on parle on parle
on parle plus du handicap on n'est plus
représenté après ça dépend des domaines
il ya des choses qui sont par exemple
moi pour me déplacer je prends les
transports je prends des taxis spéciaux
spécialement handicapés ou des oudéa
sauf comment des sociétés spéciales et
là je peux vous dire que c'est une
catastrophe ça je peux en témoigner
c'est à cause de ça que je ne sors pas
beaucoup c'est une catastrophe dont une
société qu'on voit dans tout paris je
vais pas citer le nom mais qui est
sponsorisée je crois que par la mairie
de paris
et je peux vous le dire est une
catastrophe
moi ya beaucoup à faire encore en
matière de mobilité alors je voudrais
qu'on parle
à présent de cette question dont on a
beaucoup de mal à parler finalement
c'est un tabou qui est en train d'être
brisé en partie par par le gouvernement
le droit à une vie intime et sexuelle
pour les personnes handicapées la
ministre sophie cluzel a décidé de
rouvrir ce qu'elle appelle une réflexion
éthique elle s'en est expliqué au micro
des hells et écoute j'ai ouvert ce débat
parce qu'il est dans la droite ligne de
la mission que je porte remettent les
personnes handicapées en pleine
citoyenneté dans la dignité le respect
droit de vote droit vie droit à la
parentalité est aussi droit à une vie
intime affective et sexuelle
j'ai saisi le conseil d'éthique pour que
ce débat serait ou en toute sérénité
ouah au bout de huit ans parce qu'il
avait déjà été saisi comment la société
a évolué à les voir comment ça se passe
comment la formation s'est passé dans
les pays étrangers donc tout simplement
toute sérénité rouvrir ce débat
c'est normal c'est un débat de société
et ses demandés par les personnes
handicapées
voilà il existe des assistants sexuels
en allemagne au danemark aux pays-bas
mais pas en france patricia soline le
handicap n'éteint pas évidemment le
désir de contact physique de tendresse
de vie sexuelle aussi et pourtant
comment vous vivez cette injustice là la
france ne permet pas je suis je suis
traumatisé fages
je ne comprends pas pourquoi en france
on est on est aussi en retard sur ce
sujet parce que dans d'autres pays c'est
légaliser voilà et tout se passe bien et
je peux vous assurer qu'il ya une
demande mais énorme énorme de la part de
personnes handicapées
qu'ils soient en institution ou pas
comme moi moi je suis chez moi et voilà
et moi je lui dis qu'elle nous
concrètement un peu les choses comment
on en vient à faire appel soit des
associations soit des personnes qui sont
des accompagnants des aidants sexuels
eh ben on en vient que arrivé à l'âge de
40 ans on n'a aucune expérience ni
intime et sexuelle n'est rien du tout et
qu'on n'en peut plus ça veut dire que
moi je tourne en rond au bout d'un
moment je cherchais un moyen de deux
parce que comme vous dites j'avais des
désirs j'avais des envies j'avais envie
14 qu'un corps me touche d'être serré
dans les bras
voilà de sentir de la chaleur humaine
voilà et puis aussi des sexualités
proprement dit parce qu'il faut dire les
choses
voilà on a on a besoin on a des désirs
comme tout le monde vous avez fait alors
au départ vous avez vous êtes passé par
des associations vous l'avez lu entendu
parler en fait j'ai il y a quand la
prenons en 2013 je crois la première
fois le comité national d'éthique avait
refusé déjà de mettre ça en place et
j'ai écrit un article qui a paru dans
libération ou où je disais voilà je suis
une femme et moi aussi je revendique le
droit de pouvoir faire l'amour aussi
et du coup voilà bon après j'ai eu accès
à des associations
et c'est comme ça que tout doucement ça
s'est mis en place et ces femmes comme
patricia elle trouve des gens comme vous
fabrice la jeune expliquez-nous
d'abord comment comment ça se passe
concrètement donc vous vous rencontrer
ces personnes et à un contact physique à
une manière de confiance qui s'établit
donc dans un premier temps les personnes
font une demande sur le site de la passe
d'ailleurs depuis hier les demandes ont
explosé c'est quand même bizarre donc
une fois qu'ils ont fait une demande les
demandes sont triés entre guillemets
parce que il ya tellement peu
d'accompagnants est tellement de
demandes qu'on est obligé quand même de
répondre à des demandes personnes
vraiment situation de handicap lourd
quand même juste timidité même si ça
peut être un handicap ça ne l'est pas
par rapport à notre demande c'est
dommage mais c'est comme ça pour
l'instant donc une fois qu'on a fait
cette demande
ben on met en relation avec un
accompagnant ou une accompagnante du
secteur le plus près possible pour qui
et pas trop de frais de déplacement
parce qu'ils savent ce qui se passe
il ya différents cas de figure un
parfois un aidant peut aider 2,2
personnes à ceux à se toucher lors
qu'elle ne fait pas ça fait plus que
parfois il ya plus il ya des caresses et
gardé à des actes sexuels
effectivement il ya deux démarches moi
je sois j'accompagne tout seul des
femmes en situation de handicap qui ont
vraiment besoin alors dans un premier
temps de sensualité voire de sexualité
ou d'affectif parce que ça avarie sur
les trois domaines en fait de toute
façon ou aussi j'ai accompagné des fois
des couples homosexuels qui avaient
besoin d'un accompagnement parce qu'ils
sont handicapés tous les deux et qui
peuvent pas se toucher que voilà pour
qu'il puisse avoir un acte d'amour et
bien il faut qu'il y ait quand même un
contact de corps donc
que vous répondez à ceux qui considèrent
et d'ailleurs au regard de la loi que
vous êtes dans une ferme actes de
prostitution
ça ne me gêne pas effectivement je suis
un prostitué dans cette démarche là
alors le terme en soit me dérange pas
puisque il en faut de toute façon les
prostituées dans ce monde il faut
arrêter l'hypocrisie
mais moi je considère que ma démarche
elle est vraiment différente parce que
déjà je passe énormément de temps en
amont à parler avec les personnes que ce
soit par mail par téléphone
on se rend confiance en elle alors
demandé là surtout effectivement cette
demande c'est un manque de féminité
alors soit des personnes qui sont
handicapées de naissance qui n'ont
jamais eu du tout de sensualité qui ont
été touchés que de façon médicale donc
aucune tendresse aucune affection peut
être les parents mais les parents ça
reste une affection différente on est
d'accord et elles ont besoin voilà de
sensualité tout simplement
et puis progressivement ya pu y avoir du
désir qui peut se développer parce qu'il
faut que ce soit comment il s'agit de
prestations d'accompagnement c'est comme
ça que vous êtes appelés sans que je
sois sûr on ayant qui est limitée dans
le temps alors tout le temps en amont
n'est pas facturé le temps après non
plus inquiets ce qui est facturé c'est
juste la prestation quand je passe entre
1h30 et trois heures avec la personne un
contrat dans un contrat voilà tout à
fait dans un hôtel ou à domicile
le tarif préconisée par la passe et 250
euros
il faut savoir que dans ma pratique moi
professionnel je peux gagner plus en
faisant moins longtemps
donc c'est vraiment un tarif qui est
quand même assez adaptable et nous
peut-être votre donc moi je pratique la
relation d'être psychocorporelle par le
biais du massage est entre autres le
massage tantrique cas un travail qui
travaille déjà sur l'énergie sexuelle
j'aide les personnes hommes ou femmes à
se reconnecter à leur sensibilité et
leur sexualité donc déjà cette démarche
là pour être considéré comme la
prostitution et pourtant je sais de la
thérapie ça vous choque sa débâcle
non pas du tout parce que je pense que
de choses qui me gêne esprit c'est qu'on
parle pas d'amour et parce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que vous avez besoin
aussi d'être pris dans les bras
je trouve ça extraordinaire comme phrase
parce qu'on a tous besoin d'être pris
par les bras n'y a pas à l'être humain
qui n'a pas besoin de ça donc on joue
toujours les voilà les gros bras n'a
besoin de personne non on a besoin de
l'autre n'a besoin de l'amour du regard
de l'autre sa première chose
deuxièmement bravo d'en parler comme ça
parce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que
le nombre d'appels explose bien des
compas en fait d'être humain dès qu'il
parle de sexualité un problème puisque
c'est la religion est ce que c'est la
timidité est ce que c'est notre culture
judéo chrétienne je ne sais pas on n'ose
jamais en parler mais l'histoire de mitu
c'est quoi ces femmes qui n'avaient
jamais osé parler de ce qui leur était
arrivé dès l'instant où on dit on peut
parler tout le monde en parle mais c'est
très dur
bravo de problème patricia le le le
piège non dans ce dans ce lien là c'est
qu'on peut tomber amoureux non ce que ça
vous est arrivé les mêmes pièges dont
mes mots c'est pas le sujet là c'est pas
la fevad
alors je vous répond franchement oui et
je suis bien là vivante en pleine forme
pas dépressive rien du tout c'est normal
ça arrive via de l'attachement on n'a
pas une relation intime avec un mur on a
une relation intime forte avec une
personne et non vous faites alors dans
ces cas-là rsa c'est l'asie de l'est
dans vous allez perdre et agrégé
oui c'est à moi de gérer ces situations
et je trouve que l'amour de ce n'est pas
un gros mot ce n'est pas ça arrive c'est
des sentiments il ya déjà une
interaction entre deux personnes
et donc voilà ça peut arriver mais après
à nous aussi
justement peut-être que l'argent est là
aussi et pour ça
à nous de savoir différencier les choses
on le sait moi quand je fais cette
démarche
je sais que ce n'est pas mon amoureux ou
mon amoureuse je sais que c'est une
personne qui est là pour un temps
ponctuelles pour me donner de la
tendresse et pourquoi pas un peu
d'affection aussi parce que encore une
fois voilà c'est pas un gros mot qu'il y
ait des liens qui se créent
c'est très important et repris confiance
en vous vous avez vous aviez déjà
confiance oblige impossible
j'avais compté mois plein plein voulait
les débats oui je suis comédienne donc
ça aide la semoy façon
et oui j'avais besoin j'avais besoin de
me sentir femme j'avais besoin aussi de
me sentir désiré de savoir qu'on pouvait
me touche et autres que pour la toilette
ou des soins ça c'est très important
celle là on est dans le cas de
latendresse parce qu on est enfermés
dans notre corps et quand on est
trimballé tout le temps et ben voilà là
au moins on est allé on va accueillir
aurélien pradié qui est député à l'est
républicain du lot
il est en retard nous sommes en direct
c'est pas bien aurélien pradié mais bon
il a une excuse il est le député de
l'année est qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je dise député de l'année
les républicains ont roulé pardonne son
retard bienvenue vous êtes
particulièrement investis sur les sur
les questions du handicap
je vais revenir quand même à vous parce
que on parlait de la confiance alors
patricia c'est pas son cas juste le
talent mot épanouie mais parfois vous
vous dites que ça permet aussi aux
personnes handicapées vient de
rencontrer l'âme soeur par la suite
alors justement je suis content que vous
posiez la question parce que c'est
vraiment le coeur du sujet c'est pour ça
que je fais cette démarche vis femmes
sur dix que j'ai accompagné ont
peut-être fait appel à moi une fois deux
fois trois fois quatre fois une l'a fait
un peu plus longtemps mais les autres
très rapidement elles ont repris
confiance en elle et ont retrouvé de la
féminité et on a même une dès la
première fois dès le lendemain elle et
se sentaient métamorphosé elle a
rencontré quelqu'un très rapidement donc
c'est ça qui est fantastique dans cette
démarche le but c'est pas devenir
dépendant nous c'est de les aider des
passeurs vous pouvez les aider aussi à
mettre une certaine forme de limites
parce qu'on entend le discours de
patrick launay oui cette suite moderne
tout à fait ça fait partie de la
relation dans un premier temps mais on
en a parlé avant et puis c'est une
prestation professionnelle cadrés et
heureusement parce qu'effectivement si
c'était pas cadré fait financièrement ça
pourrait déborder est très compliqué à
gérer
on revient pradier marrant on va vous
interroger directement dans le vif du
sujet au 10è le comité consultatif
national d'éthique a émis un avis
négatif sur cette question d'aider
d'aidant sexuel des assistants sexuels
12 en 2012 alors la crainte c'est
d'inciter d'une certaine façon la
prostitution
qu'est ce qu'on fait on change la loi je
ne sais pas un truc et moi j'aborde ce
sujet avec beaucoup de beaucoup
d'humilité et beaucoup de doutes je
pense que ça fait du bien en politique
aussi parfois d'avoir un peu de doute
une question extrêmement difficile à
deux égards d'abord parce qu'elle
interroge un tabou la société tout ce
qui d'ailleurs tourner autour de la
sexualité reste encore un tabou dans
notre société
et puis ensuite parce que l'objectif est
de protéger celles et ceux qui font
appel à ce type de service toujours
beaucoup de mal avec ce monde de
services de prestations sexuelles
parce qu'on est sur le rapport au corps
et patricia assouline expliqué qu' elle
n'avait été touché que par le corps
médical jusqu'à l'âge de 40 ans qu'est
ce qu'on fait mais quand on entend qu il
existe les moyens de retrouver deux
estime de soi mais ça ne va pas c'est à
mon sens c'est une fois que j'aborde
tous avec beaucoup d'humilité mais je ne
pense pas que ça puisse seulement passer
par l'acte sexuel
le rapport au corps ne peut pas être
totalement dissociée du rapport au
sentiment surtout lorsque durant toute
votre vie vous n'avez eu rapport au
corps qu'un acte médical
le jour où ce corps là qui vous touche
est autre chose qu'un acte médical
il ya très vite ça peut devenir une
situation de fragilité pour celui qui
bénéficie de cette prestation là une
fois plus ce mot et attribue donc
j'aborde tous eu toute cette question là
avec beaucoup de l'olivier paris nicole
dire aussi que la sexualité des
handicapés est à bout a oui déjà parlé
de handicap c'est un sujet qui a quand
même été très longtemps tabou en france
alors la sexualité des personnes
handicapées on est vraiment là sur un
sujet qui est allé très très pointues au
niveau de ce qui est tabou en france et
c'est extrêmement courageux au niveau
politique de le mettre sur la table et
moi je salue d'abord le courage des
personnes qui témoignent
et c'est très important que les
personnes concernées puissent s'exprimer
et dans ce débat qui s'ouvre sur le
sujet des assistants accompagnent un oui
dans sexuelle je sais pas comment on
pourrait le définir d'abord dire qu en
france il n'a y pas encore de
réglementation au niveau international
il ya le ms qui dit que la santé
sexuelle favorise le bien-être
il ya quelques pays comme l'allemagne la
suisse qui ont légiféré pour l'instant
en france on est sur une interdiction
mais le débat s'ouvre il est très
important d'écouter les différents des
différentes personnes et différents
acteurs
il ya certaines associations qui sont
favorables à l'ouverture de ce droit
certaines sont opposés à ce droit donc
la société peut être depuis 2012 a
évolué
quand on le croit et laissons faire le
débat et laissons la parole aux
personnes concernées
on entend un des responsables politiques
le débat s'ouvre on est au début d'une
réflexion on en est pas à changer la loi
serge entend bien vous en avez
conscience a bien sûr bien sûr il y aura
pas de miracle ya même des associations
de handicapés qu'ils sont contraints ça
existe je sais et ça me dépasse
d'ailleurs parce que je comprends très
bien qu'ils aient des personnes
handicapées qui disent non nous on peut
se débrouiller on n'a pas besoin de ça
ça nous stigmatisent mais en même temps
chacun il ne pense qu'a eue il ne voit
il faut voir plus loin il faut voir
certes eu peut-être qu'ils n'en n'ont
pas envie pas besoin ils sont libres
tant mieux mais il faut penser à toutes
les personnes qui n'en n'ont pas qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autre choix que ça notamment
en institution vous dites pas d'autre
choix par exemple je pense aux sites de
rencontres
ça c'est non mais totalement est
inenvisageable ça ne marche pas moi
c'est inenvisageable déjà et vous savez
quand vous allez dire handicapées vous
croyez vous croyez que on n'est pas
enfin voilà c'est pas de la charité
chrétienne les gens ils vont pas faire
ça par pitié par ils vont pas ils
veulent pas quand vous prononcez le mot
handicapés et que quelqu'un via et vois
mon handicap je peux vous assurer que je
ne trouverai personnes ça je peux vous
le certifier
fabrice rajah ce témoignage là il faut
non pas la solitude
il ya une grande solitude ça fait partie
des premiers témoignages que j'ai eu la
toute première personne que j'ai
accompagné
c'est une femme qui a vraiment beaucoup
de besoins physiques et elle faisait
appel à des hommes sur internet
justement par des sites de rencontre
mais il faut voir ce qu'elle a vécu
c'est des hommes qui viennent chez elle
pour se d'elle ou entre
guillemets excusez moi l'expression se
masturber sur elle et se barrer n'est
absolument pas s'occuper de tendresse ou
de quoi que ce soit ne pas du tout
cherché à créer un lien avec cette
personne c'est juste profiter
normalement et profiter de la personne
en plus donc c'est assez horrible comme
situation
allez merci avaient convenu que ça à un
dernier mot là-dessus aurélien pradié
avant de changer de totalement le sujet
ce sont des témoignages extrêmement
éprouvant parce qu'ils nous renvoient
mille choses
et on ne peut pas se mettre totalement à
votre place je dis simplement que la
noblesse du politique aussi c'est de ne
pas se précipiter sur des sujets aussi
dur que cela il nous faut prendre le
temps nécessaire pour que la décision
soit une décision mûrie merci on va
partir à l'elysée maintenant vous savez
sans doute ce qui se passe à l'elysée ce
soir la majorité celle à laquelle vous
appartenez même si vous n'êtes pas
député a rendez vous avec le président
de la république bonsoir stéphanie des
pierres vous êtes cela allez on y va
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce qui va se
passer ce soir c'est la grande
explication entre emmanuel macron et les
députés en marche après cet épisode
fâcheux on le rappelle du congé pour
deuil d'un enfant qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent précisément et est-ce qu'ils
ont répondu présent oui les députés ont
assez largement répondu présent ce soir
ceux de la commission retraite sont
carrément venus en bus entre deux
séances à à l'assemblée les députés et
attendre des explications après le couac
sur le congé pour le décès d'un enfant
l'appel du président à faire preuve de
plus d'humanité a été très mal vécue par
sa majorité qui s'est sentie visée
quelque chose s'est brisé entre emmanuel
macron et ceux qui l'ont suivi en 2017
les parlementaires espèrent aussi avoir
l'oreille du président beaucoup ne se
sont pas assez écoutés
la réunion a commencé il ya quelques
minutes la salle est configuré comme
pour un grand débat le président de la
république est au milieu des députés il
devrait ce soir s'employer à les
rassurer faire un peu de calinothérapie
unité et cohésion c'est le mot d'ordre
il ne faut pas laisser grandir les
frustrations ne pas laisser le lien se
déliter explique à un ministre alors
cette réunion était prévue de longue
date selon l'elysée mais elle a été un
peu avancée concède un membre du
gouvernement
et avant même le grand rendez vous de ce
soir les députés la république en marche
avait pris les devants
il propose de passer le congé pour le
deuil d'un enfant de 5 à 15 jours ouvrés
de renforcer l'accompagnement
psychologique et de verser une aide pour
les obsèques
on verra ce soir après la réunion si le
président a réussi à apaiser le climat
si la majorité est unie ou en plein
doute
le débat sur la réforme des retraites et
les municipales seront aussi à deux
autres tests importants dans les
semaines qui viennent merci beaucoup
stéphanie en direct de l'elysée un mot
là-dessus philippe douste-blazy le
psychodrame entre le président et sa
majorité qui en a marre d'être vu comme
un groupe aux ordres discipline et des
godillots et qui demande un petit peu de
respect je ne permettrai pas une
remarque institutionnels c'est très
intéressant de voir que c'est quelque
chose qui était impensable du temps du
général de gaulle même du temps de
françois mitterrand oui que l'une des
deux de la majorité
j'espère qu'on voit bien que le rôle du
premier ministre qui a toujours été
d'être le patron de la majorité le
président étant totalement au dessus et
ne se permet pas de voir qui la majorité
ou quelle opposition c'est la france et
que la france hélas aujourd'hui par les
institutions parce qu'on a changé
ce quinquennat ce septennat au
quinquennat est bien le chef de la
majorité pour tout le monde et se
rappelle le président merci philippe
douste-blazy en faire un petit coup de
chapeau pour terminer cette émission à
aurélien pradié parce que figurez vous
que le prix du trombinoscope a décidé de
vous décerner le prix du député de
l'année félicitations c'est un député de
l'opposition ça doit faire réfléchir les
marcheurs alors content de l'année oui
on peut tout dire le dernier prix que
j'ai reçues qui m'a vraiment marqué
c'est celui de député
tout court lorsque les lotois m'ont fait
confiance en me dit non non c'est pas la
fausse modestie c'est juste que il le
sait mieux que moi il ya quelque chose
de dangereux en politique c'est son
déshonneur donc j'essaie demande mon
préserver le plus possible ce qui est
certain c'est que je le disais la
dernière fois que j'ai mis les pieds à
l'hôtel de la ces qui l'hôtel la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
c'était pour me faire sermonner par
françois de rugy consignes n'étaient pas
assez sage c'est vrai mais au début les
papiers sur vous c'est le grandes
gueules les rockets les jeunes cadres à
l air les républicains qui avaient
réussi à se faire élire après quand même
la débâcle un aux législatives heures de
gaucho qu'il faut faire aussi de la
forme pas que du fond pour être à le
député de l'aisne oui il faut il faut
être soi même il faut avoir du
tempérament c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je ne déteste rien de plus que
les politiques qui n'ont pas de
tempérament dont jane est un petit gars
du sud
et mon parcours rendu là c'est aussi à
ce tempérament là ce que je souhaite
simplement ses atouts les tous les
gamins de ma génération qui viennent de
milieux qui ne sont pas des milieux
politiques de pouvoir un jour devenir
député de leur pays
moi je dois absolument tout à la
république et ce soir se met ça dit quoi
aussi que le député de l'année
appartiennent à l'opposition et non pas
à tous à cette majorité nouvelle qui
arrive comme vous d'ailleurs un sur les
bancs de l'hémicycle
ça dit beaucoup de choses de la majorité
mais sa jeunesse est d'avis et c'est un
peu les césars des députés ce soir donc
je pense que c'est pas du tout un choix
politique je pensais être certainement
le meilleur moment c'est pas ça existait
sur le trombinoscope six étudiants
connaissez bien tous plus ou moins
possédant les primates en gros vous
toutes mes félicitations et ce n'est que
le début d'une longue rire voilà c'est
fini on s'arrête là merci à tous d'être
venus sur le plateau adèle c'était merci
infiniment patricia assouline d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
avant de se quitter une pensée aussi
pour les proches et la famille de
françois andré c'est un député d'ille et
vilaine qui est décédé la nuit dernière
la bretagne a perdu un fils a déclaré
richard ferrand tout à l'heure lors de
la minute de silence à l'assemblée
françois andré avait été lui re 2012
sous l'étiquette socialiste avant de
rejoindre la république en marche
en 2010 c'est tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire jean pierre gratien
bonsoir merci et à demain
[Musique]